salvi signora come sta bene e mia mamma
le manda i saluti marina e sopra allora
io vado con permesso venera come stai
passate il monroy ha risolto la prima
vede consigliato lo sapevo lo sapevo
quella funziona sempre andiamo alla vita
dalla usa la mari lo sai che ti voglio
bene e voglio solo che tu sia felice e
quindi non voglio mancare di rispetto
pure offenderti però secondo me quel
ragazzo non fa per te dovresti trovare
qualcuno che ti meriti di più che abbia
il tuo stesso stile di vita che sia più
maturo ecco più maturo non credi
ma allora non ci arrivi proprio ma cioè
sei de coccio quante volte te lo devo
dire si è fatto tutta la scuola sa quali
sono ragazzi come tu collezioni tinte
labbra cioè vuole il wall e corna stile
monetica vuoi questo no ma la continua
così continua così continua farti del
male continua a soffrire per un pezzo di
merda quando la tua migliore amica e da
dieci anni che fiducia che lo devi
lasciare che devi lasciar perdere ma te
no perché rientra da qui e piaceri
allora sei cosi ti dico non mi chiede
che così non mi chiede più consigli
perché io mi sono stufata bastano ti
vuoi parlare
tu hai fame facciamo merenda
[Musica]
no grazie non ho tanta fame allora
arriva mar io vorrei tanto dormire qui
però non so se mi minaccia forse sì ma
carini la propria chiamare tu magari la
convinci va bene adesso prova a
chiamarla la chiami salve signora sono
marina l'amica di giulia e volevo sapere
se poteva magari dormire da me questa
sera e stiamo a casa ovviamente non lo
siamo e se vuole le passo mia mamma così
così assicura veloci poi qua noi
vogliamo sono quasi alla tre ore
ho guardato uomini e donne con tua mamma
ho fatto il complicato fratello è curato
sotto il cane ma rimango a dormire ma
vado marini hanno detto di non dirtelo
non insistere
ho dato la mia parola giada dai
veramente non mi far litigare con cioè
ma ti rendi conto vi ha detto rion
dirtelo a parte che voglio dire nessuno
si deve permettere di parlare dietro ma
poi voglio dire melo pieni di rame alla
tua migliore amica chiama ce la fai
guardate la massa di ignoranti
ma lui li stai piangendo no
figuratevi se bianco per un film dai giù
come sto benissimo perfetta come sempre
grazie allora siamo a mano come sto
amo cos'è sto schifo ma non penserai
mica di uscire così per me è no bhatti
subito a cambiare così non esci mari
senti e bellissimo meno melo poi
prestare così lo metto sabato sera
davvero grazie uomo ti prometto che ne
avrò cura è troppo tintoria e lunedì
mattina a scuola te le restituisco
grazie ciao ma domani ciao scusa dove
sta andando primi vestiti a casa con i
miei vestiti e portando a casa mi
servono per il week end da chiamo mi
servono ti prego quando me li
restituisci massimo dai suoi tra cui the
lead author
[Musica]